quelqu'un de bien
et lyon au stade de l'émission 5 7 d'or
tajan les guignols [ __ ] j'en aie aie
vous avez tenir là c'est ouais c'est
extrêmement émouvant bas je sors jamais
moi donc quand j'aimerais que des gens
nous aiment et justement
justement vous sortez jamais mais alors
si vous avez en face de vous leur diriez
quoi présent florent pagny vous diriez
quoi si vous le dis en face de vous
comme sa soirée quand on gagne son bric
on peut enfiler 50 pour que les autres
vivent
ouais il reste quand même pas le poussin
j'en ai ça par exemple c'est ça c'est un
truc c'est un peu chiant ce que je vais
raconter mais les impôts c'est le truc
le plus républicain du monde
un incident que un jour chacun va donner
de son plein gré
une partie de ce qu'ils gagnent au
prorata de ce qu'ils gagneraient donc
c'est très républicain et puis on
invente des passe-droits des trucs de
deux sorties en a qui paieront moins et
puis tout d'un coup ma fille de 8 ans un
joueur me dit papa en paie trop d'impôts
l'état c'est un voleur la quitte à 10 à
kaunas
non mais l entente et la soeur de dire
que l'état est un voleur
c'est un moment payer ses impôts ses
volets n'ont payé ses impôts c'est que
les hôpitaux fonctionnent c'est que les
écoles fonctionnent fait que les
services publics font taire ou alors on
décide qu'on veut plus de ça pour ça
mais il a voté pour son vin alors vous
savez que florent pagny vous aime pas
beaucoup il avait dit je vais me venger
en faisant une chanson la chanson
s'appelle l'homme marionnettes donc gré
c'est vous assure alors voilà les
paroles
ouais il a rien dans la tête il est
vraiment très bête
moi je suis d'accord jusqu'à la non mais
faut pas dire ça il fait ils feignent ce
qu'il a
alors on continue avec les gens que vous
rencontrez pas dans les cela aide que
vous ne sortez pas non patrick sébastien
ouais ça faisait du mal
non j'ai du mal patrick sébastien
d'ailleurs mes potes se sont marrés ya
pas longtemps parce que je disais que
j'aimais bien l'émission de patrick
sébastien le plus grand cabaret parce
que ça véhicule pour moi d des valeurs
qui sont un peu plus marrante que la
star academy c'est à dire qu'il ya des
mecs qui ont vraiment bossé ils font du
numéro peut-être à la con en tout cas
c'est des gens qui ont un véritable
talent qui par leur talent apporte du
bonheur aux gens et passe à la
télévision c'est très bien sinon patrick
sébastien est un nom que je n'aime pas
ben zid ou zid ou glasgow c'est une
merde ça me gêne pas c'est une merde ce
mec c'est un gros con sans l'ombre d'un
talent ça ça me gêne pas ah bon non
c'est ce qu'il a ajouté après sur ma
famille qui me gêne à moi je suis pas au
courant non parce qu'il a ajouté des
trucs sur ma famille et ça c'est
impardonnable
parce que ma famille elle y est pour
rien que - prennent pour un gros con
c'est pour un problème mais qu'il s'en
prenne à ma famille c'est pas bon vous
avez des infos que j'ai pas bien
guillaume durand si vous le rencontriez
comme ça une baffe dans la gueule
ah oui d'accord mais pas pour moi encore
temps pour moi pour ce qu'il a aussi dit
de la femme que j'aime
ouais est ce qu'il a dit de la femme que
j'aime c'est méprisant c'est sexiste
c'est ridicule et faux
il a dit on au service des guignols en
gros pour faire la carrière daniel
michaud osé ça non il a surtout dit
qu'elle avait passé trois heures
normale sup qu'elle passe son temps à
choisir ses robes fendi alors qu'elle
passait son temps à travailler pour lui
et que à 10 minutes de l'émission qu'ils
aient finalement je veux faire tout seul
je le sens bien ouais et que moi je
récupérerai une femme en pleurs tous les
soirs donc pour ça il aurait une tarte
dans la gueule
sayah le passé souvent ça rigole pas
bernadette chirac avec le sac c'était là
un peu loin non lorsque excuses - balma
2 voilà d'accord bon et bien voilà n'ont
cessé ces biens n'ont vraiment non mais
je vous dis ce que je pense à mais voilà
c'est bien
bon ben laden si vous l'aviez en face de
vous la khomsa spis du kunar âge le
flingue directs ied a car oui ça
rendrait service à peu ma nage le
flingue et georgia bouge pas dubaï ou
qu'est-ce qu'il dit qu'est ce qui peut
faire rien n'est pas là parce qu'il l'a
fait exprès et ouais mais c'est pas lui
alors il quelqu'un qui est pas là ce
soir mais si vous le rencontriez qu'est
ce que vous lui diriez laurent baffie
ben je lui dirai ma fille pourquoi tu me
parles plus bas ils vous envoient non
bah ouais mais c'est sa cause de la
piscine hammam
non c'est pas ça je crois que c'est plus
profond que ça chez lui ferait non je
laime moi c'est quelqu'un qui me fait
marrer ici il fallait le prévoir
c'est un mec qui me fait vraiment marrer
c'est un des rares qui me fait rire en
cas de vol et il ya eu un malentendu
parce que quand il a eu sa marionnette
avant même qu'elles sortent ces 300 kg
annuel de baisse et avant même que la
marionnette soit apparue la télé ne
parlait plus oui parce que c'est joli
mais non mais après mais bah tu sais ce
que c'est que tu commences à rire sur un
truc
le truc prends tu sais plus tard été et
puis on en a fait un peu trop voilà on
en a fait deux crocs c'est bien ça lui
fera plaisir
non mais c'est vrai je le pense je
pourrais lui dire mais comme s'il peut
point de parler alain il veut pas vous
rencontrez on dit mais je sais il vient
pas du tout non il n'ya pas maintenant
il va dit à gaccio ne va pas tu
choisirais voir ton film même si c'est
une merde
alors les guignols tout a commencé en
1988 quand alain de greef veut remplacer
les nuls et décide d'adapter un show
anglais de marionnettes qui s'appelle le
site beating images ça devient les
arènes de l'info
en 1990 elle devient les guignols vous
vous arrivez en 1992 donc pas au début
seulement quatre heures après le début
mais malgré tous les changements dans
l'équipe qui a pu avoir vous êtes
toujours l'avant bah ouais comment ça se
fait pas ce que c'est je veux dire une
bêtise bête est bête
ouais c'est vraiment le métier que
j'aime faire je savais pas qu'il
existait et c'est mon moyen d'expression
à moi y'a des gens qui aiment le cinéma
qui aiment la radio de théâtre moi c'est
mon moyen d'expression je peux y faire
du théâtre puisque canal théâtre de
marionnettes c'est une somme
ça c'est un truc pour les guignols qui
est que je trouve extrêmement émouvant
encore c'est des gens qui fabrique des
marionnettes à la main des manipulateurs
de donc sont des intermittents du
spectacle il ya des voix il ya des
maquis des habits et des réalisateurs
dont celui de cette émission
tu sais petit métier fabrique tous les
jours pendant dix minutes une vraie
émission dérivée
c'est quand même un vrai travail qui
fait travailler à 200 fiches de paye
pour moi c'est un gros boulot c'est à
dix jeunes plus ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire tous ils aiment ce qu'ils font
et moi j'adore faire ce que je fais
alors quand on me dit tu en as pas marre
n'ont jamais on n a pas de raison non
j'aime il ya quand même des gens qui
regardent les guignols tous les soirs ça
va dans les soirs bas de 2 millions 7,1
les soirs où comme là on est en ce
moment à 3 millions 5
c'est énorme avec des pointes à 4
millions deux jours on a 17 d'or mais
les mecs se barde si c'est pas pour nous
pourquoi on a donné raison à ses
collègues
alors ça vous fait quoi aujourd'hui de
bosser entre eux emmanuel chat et
stéphane bern
la vie change ouais ma vie change n'y a
pas de contacts c'est une des choses qui
n'est plus désagréable aujourd'hui c'est
que avant il y avait un contact alors
c'était toujours mieux avant on s'en
fout mais avant il y avait un contact
une continuité qui faisait que c'était
il y avait une homogénéité à cette
chaîne mais non il y en a plus il y à
chaque fois son émission dans son coin
berne guergis l'acier nous qui faisons
la nôtre en direct à midi font la leur
on serait un contre pas et puis voilà
bout d'un moment
on sent bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui
se délite on ne peut pas être solidaire
à pourquoi tout le monde a quitté canal
à part vous et philippe dana ça fait pas
gentil bah moi parce que j'aime ça donne
parce qu'il peut pas ça c'est pas gentil
non plus alors vous allez dire été
censuré par la direction mais eux la
nouvelle direction la whey ah ouais
ouais
sur quoi sur un sketch
qui parlait de canal+ était l'arrivée 2
de stéphane bern à canal ouais et il
trouvait avec l'ambiance qu'on avait mis
autour de ça était un peu trop militaire
ouais donc ils ont dit on passe pas le
sketch il ya eu réunion j'ai dit voilà
moi c'est toujours pareil
vous êtes le patron c'est vous qui
décidez ce qui passe à l'antenne et
jacques reflète la censure si elle est
trois fois par semaine je prends mes
responsabilités si elle est une fois par
an on discute la lescure lescure
innocence et oscillations de greffe
aussi je suis allé trop loin
bien sûr toutes les directions pour moi
non pas le monde ce que vous dites c'est
que c'est pas ça va c'est supportable
est très supportable
alors on parle un petit peu tous
maintenant bruno gaccio parce qu'on
reconnaît les guignols dont vous connais
moins vous êtes né en 1958 par an
prolétaires ah ouais ouais c'est à dire
c'est à dire papa maçon mais pas pas
entreprendre formation n'a s'il partait
qu'on a quatre fours loyal et sur les
murs et puis voilà c'est un [ __ ] ma
mère est pas peu fiers ils sont tous les
deux à la retraite je crois qu'il gagne
en ce moment aux alentours de 7 mille
balles par mois la retraite 2 à 2 baa2
mon travail et mon père a cotisé
quarante sept ans si vous pouviez lâcher
un peu de thunes pour papa samba n'a
donc en france à saint-etienne
l'adolescence vous fait les 400 coups
vous êtes parfait autodidacte on peut
dire
fuyez le lycée à l'âge de 15 ans vous
raté même le père vous ratez un crp
typographe non ah bon j'arrête avant et
je peux regarder des chèvres et oui
c'est ça oui chevry en ardèche
ah ouais ce que je vis une barbe et les
cheveux jusque là non non c'était
vachement plus rigolo de ça et c'est
vachement plus rigolo et ça c'était on
est parti avec un copain bourdeau dans
la drôme et on a gardé des chèvres voilà
on s'est occupé de chèvre elle avait 80
cm elle était très bien on a gagné le
prix du picodon drôme ardèche
kroll avec monsieur tron il s'appelait
c'était conan ou à la maison
non mais c'est vrai j'ai fait ça pendant
un an et demi d'accord et alors tout va
bien ah ouais j'adorais simplement comme
boulot quand tu as pensé à ça quand tu
étais prothèse à moi j'ai gardé des
moutons alors ça aussi ça s'appelle des
élèves
ça s'appelle des élèves exception non
j'ai gardé des moutons des vrais moutons
vrai mais arrêtez de 5000 à moutons je
découvre pas du tout obligé de faire le
bruit ils comprennent j'ai raté j'ai
raté mes jeux
je suis content j'ai perdu plein de
trucs alors donc à l'âge de 20 ans bruno
vous arrivé à paris en 1983 vous rentrer
petit théâtre de bouvard et puis vous
commencé à écrire des sketches dont le
fameux trisomique de timsit qui lui a
valu tellement de malheurs à spock
timsit bongor 1 vont regretter sa ba non
non c'est un personnage odieux qui dit
des choses aux gars mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que j'y fasse
justement je vais pas m'excuser
personnellement c'était pas un
trisomique c'est un garagiste way qui
disait tout bêtement que ben chez les
trisomiques c'est comme les crevettes
roses à part la tête tout est bon c'est
pas la balle la plus classe du monde
mais en fait non pas fait pendant un an
ouais au spectacle il a sorti la
cassette ça a duré un an on l'a vendu le
spectacle passe sur france 2 les mecs
vous à sa up pour interdire la casse et
ouais mais on a déjà vendu la casse avec
un an et demi qu'elle remonte bien alors
ce plan personnel bruno gaccio je crois
que le plus simple pour savoir comment
s'est passé votre vie privée
c'est d'aller voir le démon de midi au
michèle bernier qui racontent des scènes
de votre vie conjugale puisque michel
après quelques années passées le bruno
gaccio on a fait une pièce cas beaucoup
de français c'est une adaptation d'une
bande dessinée de florence cestac c'est
le sage
vous vous reconnaissez pas du tout je me
reconnais et vous allez vous reconnaître
aussi mais c'est un spectacle que j'ai
beaucoup aimée parce que une rupture
c'est toujours difficile et c'est un
spectacle qui l'a un peu guéri et pour
la première fois elle a joué la comédie
en étant d'une énorme sincérité et quand
je suis allé la voir son lui dire j'ai
vu la salle se levait et j'ai été émue
pour elle c'était très mineures et puis
la nuit d'ivresse et l'excellente aussi
moi je craigne j'enlèverai la robe rouge
mais bon sinon elle être exact michel
cymes nous regardent comme des oeufs
alors sur le plan financier vous devez
être très riche non non je gagne très
bien ma vie je suis à l'aise mais je
suis pas riche dont bruno tu veux je te
dise combien je gagne
ouais c'est ridicule seize mille euros
par mois + ses droits d'auteur
quelquefois cent mille balles salon ça
fait un peu plus de son miré voulait pas
trop perdu quand l'action vivant de
l'universel s'est écroulé j'ai donné mon
slip mes chaussettes j'ai plus rien j'ai
pu observer
ah bah oui parce que quand faut dire la
vérité vous avez investi quand vous qui
faites la world company vous êtes
investi votre l'union c'est une oraison
adversaire doucement ils m'ont fait
l'amitié de mes filets
copieux à gérer donc j'ai écrit une
lettre à lescure un jour du bilan le
vieil anar que je suis recevoir des
stock options ça me fait bien marrer moi
et je vais les garder quand même
renseigné on m'a dit les stock options
tant docu pas tu prends tu mets dans un
tiroir si ça marche un jour tous les
ressorts et à de l'argent j'ai dit on
fait comme ça et puis j'avais confiance
moi dans ces maisons là j'en ai acheté
un petit peu ouais pas trop j'espère un
peu trop un peu trompeuse il fait [ __ ]
non parce qu'il ya un article j'adore
dans le proxy dans le new york times
vous expliquent qu'ils ont été ruinés en
bourse et moi je trouve ça
extraordinaire de voir conneries avant
non mais je partais de l'idée quelqu'un
d'abord ça veut dire que j'ai écrit un
article dans le new york times et
respectable non mais c'est très les
joueurs bien que tu me demandes
non mais mais c'est bah oui je partais
de l'idée que qu'un type qui achètent
des actions pense toujours faire un
profil différent un profit il fait un
pourboire
celui qui fait le profit c'est celui qui
possède le million d'actions cesser les
dirigeants qui font des profits et il
joue avec les petits actionnaires c'est
juste ça qu'il faut comprendre la bourse
est pas la roulette c'est une roulette
tout s'est toujours bien numéro qui sort
ces sites vous avez compris ça
maintenant
montréal on tient la rédac en mai le
dernier truc qui vous restez quand même
du capitalisme sayed assez fine il mais
c'est pas le capitalisme c'est le
capitalisme bien fait ouais moi je pense
je suis un imbécile qui pense que tous
les systèmes fonctionnent on parlait de
cuba tout à l'heure moi je pense que le
système communisme communiste ça peut
fonctionner pourquoi ça fonctionnerait
pas chacun fabrique pour l'état l'état
redistribue à chacun selon ses besoins
pourquoi pas sauf que quand ça arrive en
hausse et des êtres humains qui en haut
je garde tout bon bain après on bikes
rêve voilà système capitaliste c'est la
même chose si chacun un mec fabrique
il vend un produit bon on dit très bien
il vend son produit tout le monde achète
le produit les gens qui fabriquent le
produire les pays bien tout va bien tout
le monde gagne de l'argent et le système
fonctionne sauf que quand ça arrive aux
patrons y regardent et puis là on voit
aux ouvriers cette nouvelle par mois
pour mon père quand il est à la retraite
et votre jeunesse ma mère aussi
donc il ya un truc qui fonctionne pas
c'est tout dites moi vous avez continué
comme ça longtemps sur canal pour
récupérer le prion vous avez perdu en
bourse la habana il faut que j'y aille
vraiment jusqu'à la retraite
ça vous manque pas parce que quand on
vous présente la bruno gaccio le patron
des guignols tout le monde applaudit
j'aimerais pas de formidables mais voilà
mais c'est simplement pas de pas être
une star comme ceux que vous allumez
tous les soirs
8 heures alors j'ai deux problèmes avec
ça vous avez dit que j'avais fait le
théâtre de bouvard
ouais donc je montrais ma tête à la tv à
l'époque il y avait 15 ou 16 millions de
personnes qui regardaient tous les soirs
il y avait trois chaînes à l'époque les
gras c'est quand même mieux et il y
avait 15 millions de personnes et dans
la rue les gens me taper dans le dos je
vous aiguiller en sort vous êtes con con
non monsieur je suis pas content
con je te dis que je suis pas con konaré
au bout d'un moment je ne sais pas gérer
ça je gère très mal le côté familier et
donc le mon ego est complètement flatté
par les guignols puisque c'est mon
travail qui est reconnu et j'adore ça et
de temps j'ai reçus par thierry ardisson
et je m'emmerde de ma tête et ça va
c'est pas trop mal bon voilà je sais que
demain matin quand j'irai chercher mon
pain on me dira je vous aiguille hier
fallait pas faire comme la télé vous
aurez à vivre vous aurez le meilleur
pain de la boulangerie
ouais alors le plus gros dommage
collatéral des guignols pour moi en tous
les cas c'est c'est guillaume durand osé
vraiment failli tuer enfin c'est ce
qu'il dit dans son livre est vraiment
poussé vraiment n'est pas obligé de le
croire
ouais ouais ouais bon là oui alors il a
fait un bouquin chez grasset qui
s'appelle la peur bleue il dénonce votre
racisme social il y voilà
gaccio ccc un fils de prolo il déteste
les riches la moine cravate le moindre
soupçon match on est vomi socialement et
un vomissement sociales exprimées par
des types qui gagnent des fortunes en
plus dire que il vous reproche
finalement vous le prohon de le voir
attaquer parce que c'est un fils de
bourgeois
mais en fait de gagner beaucoup plus de
pognon que les bourgeois c'est du pur
fantasme
c'est la susceptibilité blessé d'un type
qui a raté un truc là qui cherche un
responsable il a pensé que de greffe et
moi on voulait le dégommer c'est
absolument ridicule
je ne sais pas y'a rien à répondre à ça
c'est un truc ridicule
alors il a déclaré guillaume durand nous
sommes en balance vous nous sommes dans
la boucherie militante qui se prendrait
pour la cause du peuple alors évidemment
vous n'y couperez pas bruno gaccio on va
vous faire une interview bof pas